the jabs are ready to go but are people
ready to get them
perhaps not booster clinics should be
busier
those getting jabbed don't understand
the reluctance if they've had two and
they won't have the third it's very hard
to explain
i mean i understand those people who
don't have it at all they just make life
difficult for everybody else
we are a bit
too devil may care about the whole thing
we feel that the wave has passed over us
a lot of us have been vaccinated and
that's enough
more than 3.8 million people have had
their covid booster but over 4 million
who are eligible have not
this partly explains why the yellow line
shows every week 1.3 million people are
getting booster jams but as the brown
line shows every week another 2 million
people become eligible
only 47 percent of over 80s who are
double vaccinated have had their booster
that figure is even lower in the younger
age groups who had their second vaccine
later
and it's worrying health chiefs whilst
it's
it's great that people are coming
forward for their boosters they are not
coming forward as quickly when they
receive their invitation as we certainly
saw for the for the first jabs
so it's uh it's really important
that we now
absolutely do get the message out that
is covid is still with us
the reason boosters matter is simple
without them immunity fades and if
immunity fades infections and
hospitalizations could rise that puts
pressure on the nhs and even risks a
return of
restrictions covered cases are already
creeping up and rates are highest among
children the 12 to 15 year old vaccine
rollout has slowly started but with half
term and christmas come concerns about
mixing one public health director has
told schools to bring back bubbles what
we're seeing now is an increased rate of
number of children off school so
particularly now it's our time to say
here's some further action here's some
further suggestions and recommendations
for schools to take
with the primary aim of keeping those
pupils at school
children can now visit vaccine clinics
during half term to help the rollout
keep up with increasing infections
otherwise we'll be well into winter
before our most vulnerable are properly
protected laura bundock sky news